hey 42 here there's no denying that the
world is a scary place
on any given day there are hundreds
perhaps thousands of things that could
kill you maim you or interrupt your wifi
connection
it's no surprise that people are afraid
some of these fears make perfect sense
like
acrophobia the fear of heights
fanatophobia
the fear of dying or chianophobia
the fear of keanu reeves but
other fears seem so ridiculous that it
sounds like someone just made them
up which they did there's
arachibotorophobia
the fear of peanut butter sticking to
the roof of your mouth and
anatody of phobia the fear that you're
being watched by a dog
but what about a teomophobia
the fear of an asteroid hitting earth
is that really so crazy the answer to
that question depends on two main
factors
what kind of harm an asteroid would
cause if it hit our little planet
and whether there is any genuine risk of
this happening
in the first place i think most of us
appreciate that a massive hunk of rock
hurtling through space
at 80 000 kilometers an hour is likely
to put it about as mild as wensleydale
break a few plant pots upon its impact
with our home
and you'd be right but just how many
plant pots are going to be turned back
into wet clay
depends largely on the size of the rock
it's widely accepted nowadays that the
age of the dinosaurs was brought to an
abrupt
end by the arrival of a pretty large
boulder
estimated to measure about 10 kilometers
across
the chick's chulub asteroid crashed into
what we
now call mexico about 65 million
years ago the impact would have released
more energy than a billion
atom bombs or 12 cases of tequila
and left behind a crater 180 kilometers
wide of course none of those statistics
would have impressed the dinosaurs
who despite ruling earth for 135 million
years
still didn't know how to open a beer
never mind do data analysis
instead they went for a rather
unpleasant process called
extinction and haven't been heard from
since
that's not surprising given what
happened after the asteroid plowed into
the planet
the sheer magnitude of iv set off a
chain reaction
of earthquakes landslides and tsunamis
as far away as corinde argentina
perhaps even worse on the apocalypse
scale
the impact shot tiny bits of rock and
other debris
called spherules as high as 60
kilometers into the air
as these fee rules began to fall back to
earth
they became superheated particles of
intense
infrared radiation it literally rained
fire across the world for hours
scientists call this a thermal pulse
which sparked wildfires across the
planet
and burnt up most of the living
creatures on land
but then things didn't get much better
for the survivors
the dust driven into the atmosphere by
the asteroid impact
mixed with soot from a planet's worth of
fires
and blocked out the sun for a full year
with no sunlight there was no
photosynthesis
which meant vegetation and phytoplankton
the foundations of most ecosystems were
mostly wiped out
on the whole what one might call
cataclysmic
recent studies though suggest that this
dino killer asteroid
might have been a cosmic joke compared
to a predecessor
thought to have hit earth just over
three billion years ago
it's likely to have left a crater 500
kilometers wide
and would have blackened the skies and
caused the surface of the oceans
to boil the crater is so large
it hasn't been possible to map it yet
the asteroid may have even been
responsible for creating the system of
plate tectonics
that have defined geology and movement
of continents
ever since so it's clear that
a really big asteroid hitting earth
would be a cause for concern
and by concern i obviously mean blind
panic
chaos and disorder but what would happen
if we got bumped by a smaller rock is
that something worth worrying about
in february 2013 a meteor shower over
the oral mountains in russia
saw a series of explosions in the sky as
space rocks burnt up in the earth's
atmosphere
one object estimated to be only 18
meters
in diameter exploded with such force
that it injured more than a thousand
people and created a sonic boom that
blew out
windows and damaged hundreds of
buildings
that size roughly 20 meters across
is considered to be the minimum an
asteroid needs to be
to be lethal but i'm afraid
that was just a taster of what we could
expect if something
larger headed our way since humanity's
very short existence hasn't seen any
catastrophic asteroid collisions
most of what we've deduced about the
results of asteroid impacts come from
geological research
but in 2017 a group of scientists at
southampton university
got bored of learning and decided to see
how we're all going to die
because they use computer models to
simulate 50
000 asteroid strikes around the globe
they modeled what would happen if
asteroids ranging from 15 meters to 400
meters wide
collided with earth and then calculated
the percentage of deaths that may be
attributed
to each of seven different effects
shock waves wind blasts heat
flying debris cratering seismic shaking
and tsunamis the study showed that if
earth gets hit by an asteroid
the thing you have to worry about the
least is flying debris
unless of course the asteroid is landing
in your garden
in which case there's no point worrying
about anything
by far the deadliest consequences of an
asteroid
impact will be wind and shock waves
which would theoretically account for
60 percent of all deaths combined
perhaps you're wondering how wind could
possibly be
so dangerous well this wind would make
a hurricane look like that thing you do
on the couch after you've eaten too many
lentils
the closest example we might have is the
wind pressure wave
from a volcanic eruption which have been
known
to knock over forests like a pile of
matchsticks
or the tunguska event from 1908
when a comet or meteor exploded over
siberia
and flattened miles of trees but
that still doesn't compare to the wind
from a major asteroid impact which would
flatten
entire cities as for the shock waves
they'd be powerful enough to rupture all
your internal organs
cheerful the study showed that on
average an asteroid
400 meters across would result in up to
000 casualties there's no doubt
that's a large hunk of rock but it's
nowhere near the top end of the scale
the largest asteroid we know of is
called ceres
which at 975 kilometers
in diameter is large enough to be
classified as a dwarf planet
then there's vesta which was also
initially mistaken for a planet
with a girth of 525 kilometers
followed by at least eight more
asteroids over 250 kilometers wide
none of which you'll be pleased to hear
are headed our way
of course being hit by any of these
would spell the end of the world
even youtube but an asteroid doesn't
need to be anywhere near that big
to cause a global catastrophe scientists
estimate that
any space rock bigger than one kilometer
in size
could bring about the end of human
civilization
fantastic so that brings us to the
second factor in our
armageddon risk assessment how likely
are we to be hit by an asteroid
and how afraid should we really be
according to nasa more than 100 tons of
dust and sun-sized
particles collide with earth every day
but they are obviously all burnt up in
the atmosphere an asteroid the size of a
car
enters the earth's atmosphere about once
a year
but mostly burns up before hitting the
surface
every two thousand years we receive a
space rock about the size of a football
field
which delivers significant damage but to
a local
area asteroids that are large enough to
threaten our life on earth
only show up about once every few
million years
so the odds seem in our favor
asteroids comets and lost ufos
whose orbits bring them into close
proximity with earth
are known as near-earth objects and
astronomers have located
approximately 93 percent of all
near-earth objects
sized one kilometer or more none of
these
pose any problems except possibly for
tutatus
a two and a half kilometer asteroid
shaped like a giant potato
due to its interactions with different
planets tutatus has
a chaotic orbit so scientists can't make
accurate long-term predictions about its
movements
we expect it to be headed in our general
direction
sometime around 2069 but we don't know
how close that encounter will be
it will probably sail past without
worries
but there is a chance we end up as
potato salad
of course near-earth objects smaller
than a kilometer in size
can still deliver a really nasty blow
and
this is where things start to get a
little worrying
scientists have already classified
dozens of asteroids as potentially
hazardous
and research using infrared telescopes
has confirmed
that there are about 15 000 asteroids
larger than 100 meters in size
that still need to be identified
and then if you widen the net to include
all
asteroids the same size or bigger than
the one that exploded over russia we're
talking about
millions that's problematic
because if an unidentified asteroid
or an asteroid whose orbit was altered
in some way
was detected heading towards earth we
would need a pretty significant heads up
to plan our response
very recently nasa's center for
near-earth object studies
ran a series of simulations which showed
that even if we had six months warning
of an asteroid heading for earth
we'd be screwed bruce willis has refused
to help out again
and we just don't have the technology to
prevent a collision
it turns out lasers aren't really a
viable option for disintegrating
asteroids
and nuclear weapons are more likely to
just shatter the space rock into a
massive shrapnel
that still causes widespread devastation
to try to solve this problem nasa's
planetary defense coordination
office currently has two options it sees
as potentially promising
the first is what's called a gravity
tractor quite simply a large spaceship
would be sent to fly next to the
asteroid
and because that spaceship has a small
amount of gravity
the asteroid would be gradually pulled
off course
and sail safely past earth
another alternative is a kinetic
impactor which
involves using a spacecraft as a
battering gram
to smash into an asteroid and knock it
off course
this idea will be tested next year as
part of a mission
nasa has dubbed the double asteroid
redirection test
or dart this follows on from the failed
solar helix asteroid redirection test
or shot which was a bit embarrassing for
everyone involved
the target for the dart mission will be
an asteroid called didymus
or more specifically a smaller moonlet
that orbits didymus
the larger asteroid didymus a is about
780 meters in diameter
whilst the moonlit didimus b is about
160 meters
making it typical of the asteroids that
are more likely to threaten our
well-being on earth
didymus a and b are not dangerous but
they will pass close to earth
in october 2022 at which time
the dart probe will crash into the
moonlet
at 6.6 meters per second hopefully
deflecting it off course by just one
percent
it's comforting to know that there are
plans afoot to build an asteroid defense
weapon
but that doesn't help us much if we
don't see the big rock heading for us in
the first
place with technologies currently
available
we basically only see asteroids when we
have a telescope pointed directly at
them
that leaves a whole lot of sky uncovered
as proved by a number of occasions in
which asteroids
have slipped through the asteroid i
mentioned earlier that exploded over
russia
was totally unexpected more concerning
still
was asteroid 2019 okay
a 57 to 130 meter wide space rock
that passed just 73 000 kilometers from
earth
in july 2019 that's
less than one-fifth of the distance to
the moon
and astronomers had no idea it was
coming
by the way things have been going i'm
surprised it wasn't followed up by
2020 not okay currently 140 meter and
larger asteroids are being discovered
as a rate of about 500 per year which
means we're looking at a few decades
before
all the unidentified asteroids are
mapped
fortunately in 2025 nasa and an
organization called
the planetary society are launching a
spacecraft called the neo surveyor
which they believe will be able to
detect 90 percent
of near-earth objects of 140 meters or
larger
whilst asteroids in this size range are
unlikely to end the world as we know it
they could be capable of setting human
civilization
back a few centuries and killing
hundreds of millions of people
those consequences sound terrifying but
before you grab your tin spaghetti and
head for your backyard bunker
take solace in the fact that probability
is on your side
the chances of a major asteroid event
occurring
in your lifetime are ridiculously low
yes i know the dinosaurs said the exact
same thing
but really what did they know thanks for
watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks